Let's see.
>> Blood on your hands. This is what also
what makes you perfect.
>> Hey. Hey. Okay. So, listen to this.
Elisha fed 100 people.
>> Jesus is perfect in every way.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Elisha fed 100 people
in your book.
>> Welcome, Mr. Mr. Avery. Welcome to my
live. You're welcome to answer
the last time you were here. Mr. Avery,
you didn't answer you. One second, bro.
You said that Jesus showed his divinity
by doing miracles and claims. You just
added the two things together. You never
really did answer. So that's not a real
answer.
>> Actually, are you requesting now? But
I'm only taking one guest at a time. So
you got to come back.
>> You got to come back. [laughter]
>> Once we finish can come up, y'all. Every
can come up.
>> Well, you drop down. Drop down if you
want to drop down. Brian,
>> not together. I'm not I'm not having two
Christians up tonight. One Muslim, one
Christian. That's my rule.
>> So So So after you're done with him,
I'll come back.
>> Oh, fantastic.
>> Look at these guys.
>> I love my Christian brothers. He said,
"You know what? No, let logic up. Let
let logic up. I love it.
>> Time nephew, where you been at, man? You
don't visit me no more. You don't talk
to me in the chat.
>> You just ignore me whenever I come
around.
>> I don't ignore you.
>> What's up with that?
>> I don't ignore you. You know,
>> you do. You see me come to Don's live
sometimes. You don't say what's going
on. Uh like you used to do that. You
don't like
>> you know you wasn't on stage. I don't I
>> me or something like that.
>> I don't pay attention comment section
like that, man.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. All right. No
problem. How you doing, man?
>> You know I love you, man. Come on now.
>> Christian love.
>> Christian love, baby. Christian love.
>> Christian love. All right. Answer the
prompt here. How did Jesus demonstrate
this? But before you do,
>> it's the same as anybody else. People
make claims. Anybody can claim anything,
right? and prophets and messengers,
they're given miracles and these things
are from God, but it doesn't make you
God. So, how did Jesus demonstrate his
divinity?
>> Yeah. So, similar to what I told you
last time, and you didn't really you
wasn't able to deal with it. Um, and so
this is a nonwer.
>> You can say that. Just saying is not a
response. The way that Jesus
demonstrated his divinity, one is the
claims that he made. Claiming to be the
first and the last, claiming to be the
giver of eternal life, claiming to be
the one who forgives sins or is has the
authority to uh give somebody else the
ability to forgive sins in his name. Um
giving other people the ability to do
miracles. He did this and he proved that
he is what he said he not just by
claiming it but by doing it. He gave the
apostles the ability to do the works and
miracles to show that they were sent by
him. Um he poured out the spirit, the
holy spirit on them, giving them
miraculous uh the disciples miraculous
powers and he rose himself from the dead
like he said he would. So everything he
said about himself was vindicated from
the dead.
>> Oh yeah. So everything he said about
himself was vindicated by the works that
followed in the proofs.
>> Okay. So here all you've done so far
>> Yes sir. is mentioned the same two
things which don't make you God.
>> Oh, so so just to be clear, you're
saying that when someone claims that
they're God and demonstrates
>> doesn't make them God.
>> I I agree that a simple claim doesn't
make you God. But what about the works
that follow that show that you know you
do works that only God can do? Does that
make you does that demonstrate your God?
>> Miracles are given by God. It doesn't
make you god.
>> All right. So let let's get a given. You
see what go
>> if miracles are given to any man let's
name some of those miracles right
raising the dead even raising yourself
as you claim Jesus did even though it
doesn't say he raised himself it says he
claimed that he would but then
everywhere after that it says that God
raised him but in any particular case
which is a miracle um being able to
allow people to heal if you're given
that power and you give it to somebody
else still a miracle if you walk on
water still a miracle from the heavens
>> who gives If you heal the sick, it's
still a miracle from the heavens. If you
whatever you do, as it says in Acts
2:22, it's given. It's not you doing it.
It's God doing it.
>> So, it doesn't make you God. So, it
doesn't prove your divinity if you're
doing those things. It only proves that
God gave it to you. Now, if you can
Well, there's nothing you can you can do
about this. This is a catch 22, as a
matter of fact, because no matter what
you say, it's going to fall under two
categories. Either it's going to be a
miracle or it's going to be a claim.
>> Okay.
>> Both of them don't prove that you die.
>> I got you. I got you. So, there's
there's a few things I disagree with.
One, you talking about uh like you kind
of try to diminish Jesus saying that he
raised himself up from the dead, which I
don't know. It's like a that's it's
interesting to me because Jesus said it
multiple times. He says, "You you
destroy this temple and in three days I
will raise it up." Talking about the
temple of his body. And then he says in
John 10, he says,"I lay down my life. No
one takes it from me. I lay it down on
my own accord. I have the authority to
lay it down and the authority to pick it
back up again." So he demonstrates that
he is the one who raises himself from
the dead along with the father and the
spirit. They work in tandem together in
unison. So my thing is this. If you're
going to just say no, no, no, no, no,
no. This doesn't prove it. This doesn't
prove it. You said that God is the one
who gives miracles, right? God is the
one who gives the miracles.
>> Do you agree? Do you disagree with that?
>> I agree. I agree with you that God is
the one who gives the miracles. So my
question for you is this great along
with the standard. Did Jesus give
miracles?
>> No, he did.
>> So So did the apostles do miracle
working power through the authority and
power of Jesus?
>> Yes. The authority that was given to him
>> given to them. Wait, whoa, whoa. Who
gave the apostles the authority and the
ability to do miracles?
>> Jesus Christ through God Almighty.
>> Don't say that.
>> It was the miracle. It was the miracle
of God that he was able to do anything
even give those miracles to the
disciples. It all comes from one source.
You have to go back to the source. The
source comes down. It allows you to do
things because the one receiving this
gives it to you. It doesn't make the one
receiving it God. It makes the one who
sent it God. Back to the source.
>> I like that. I like what you just said.
It makes the one who sent it God. Who
sent the apostles these miracles?
>> God.
>> Okay. I I like that. See, I and and I
agree with you. God from the heavens.
Who did Peter say when he healed the the
lame person
>> uh in the middle of the marketplace?
>> You're going to have to bring me the
verse.
>> Okay. This is in Acts chapter This is in
Acts chapter 3. And he tells you who
he's doing this miracle by. By what
power he's doing this miracle by. Who
this God is. He tells
>> Acts 3 what? Uh, let me
>> I'll read it for the audience.
>> Let me just go through it a little bit.
>> Let me just skim. All right. The lane
beggar. Um, okay. It begins in verse
one, but let's let me just skim through.
>> I appreciate you guys coming to my live.
Tap your screen. If you haven't followed
me, go ahead and follow me. Ah, here it
is.
>> And hit the [clears throat] heart at the
top. Share this to your story. Thank you
for watching CCC TV. I have my guest
Avery here tonight. And we the question
at hand is Christians, how did Jesus
demonstrate his divinity?
>> People make claims, prophets do
miracles, but how did Jesus demonstrate
his divinity? Uh Avery now is answering
with Acts chapter 3. We don't know the
verse yet.
>> Okay. So there's there's two there's two
passages I want you to read in this.
Okay.
>> Um so you're going to read verse 6.
That's where he initially heals the lame
person. And then you're going to read uh
verse and then you're gonna read verse
16 after that. Okay. So verse six and
verse 16.
>> Verse six. All right. I'm reading verse
six. Now it reads, just give me a
second. One second. It reads, "But Peter
said, I have no silver and gold, but I
give you what I have. In the name of
Jesus Christ of Nazareth, walk." Okay.
And then what's the second one?
>> Verse 16.
>> 16. Here we go. And his name by faith
and his name has made this man strong
whom you see and know and the faith
which is through Jesus has given this
man or given the man this perfect health
in the presence of you all.
>> No problem with it.
>> So according to Peter Awesome
>> what were you trying to prove with this
verse?
>> We're about to do this. According to
Peter, who did he say is the one who uh
it's through his power and by his might
and by his name, his authority that this
miracle was done
>> by his authority and by his might. This
one would be referring to Jesus Christ.
>> Awesome. And so now look, we we have a
common ground. Our common ground that we
established is that
>> it's God who gives the miracles. God is
the one who gives the miracles, no one
else. So the fact that even Peter says
that this miracle isn't done by me, but
it's Jesus who gave this miracle, this
means and demonstrates that Jesus is
God, even according to the standard we
set.
>> Okay, great. I I like that train of
thought that you have.
>> Thank you.
>> The problem uh Google's Google's
listening to us.
>> Problem is is that Jesus's power that he
gave wasn't his own. That's the problem.
In Acts 2:22, it says, "Men of Israel,
hear these words. Jesus of Nazareth, a
man attested to you by God with mighty
works and wonders and signs, which God
did." Who did it? Who did it, Avery?
>> God did.
>> There you go. Jesus didn't do it. Jesus
didn't give them anything in actuality.
>> How many left?
>> God did it.
>> Okay?
>> You see, so whatever Jesus did, God gave
it to him. And whatever the disciples
did indirectly, yes, Jesus did
something, but ultimately God did.
>> Wait, Jesus did something.
>> We go back to square one
>> argument.
>> Yes, of course he did. He was a prophet
of God. Of course, he had powers to do
things. But those powers that he gave or
he did comes from one source as it says
in Acts 2:22.
>> Okay. So, here's my thing now. Okay. So,
we see that in Acts I mean we're going
to deal with Acts two as well because
it's it's a it should be well you're
saying me you guys are
>> let my guest let my guest speak D. We're
not fighting him tonight.
>> Appreciate it. So, uh we actually walked
away from Acts three. Um Dawood We were
in Acts three which I have no problem
going in Acts two as well because they
go hand in hand together. What we see
here is is that we see that it's Christ
who does the miracles through the
through the apostles as we already
acknowledged and conceded to. Then we
also have we also have uh um that it
stated that God
>> Oh, that thought somebody's knocking on
one door. One one second. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry.
>> Come on, man.
>> One second. I'm still I still I still
got you in my ear. One second.
>> All right. All right.
>> I miss you, too. Here we go.
>> Sorry about that.
>> All right. All right. Go ahead.
>> All right. So, [clears throat] this is
my thing.
>> All right. So, in Acts three, we saw who
is the one by whose power it was that
the miracle was done. And that was
through Jesus. It was done in his name
by faith in him that the miracle was
done. Right? And we already seen that
that was Jesus. We said that the one who
gives the miracles is God. So the fact
that we now go to Acts two where it
talks about how God did works through
Jesus meaning the father did works
through Jesus is not a negation of Jesus
also doing works through the apostles
right here as we see the father does
work through Jesus Jesus does works
through the apostles just like how the
father did work through him now this is
what's amazing about this in Acts two
watch this uh can you read start at
verse uh 16 cuz right right before you
read uh 22 I love Acts 2 cuz it actually
proves the deity of Christ.
>> Stay stay in Acts chapter 2.
>> Acts what?
>> Acts 2.
>> Okay. Go back cuz I was in Acts 3 right
now to what
>> you're going to read verse 16 to 21
right before the verse. Lost lost
connection. Hold on. What is going on?
Out of whack. Okay. Thank youv.
>> I'm your host General Creed. If you
haven't followed me, go ahead and
follow. Check out some of my content on
my profile. I got a few videos up. My
YouTube uh channel has been kind of like
abandoned, but I got a few videos on
there, too. Pretty soon, I'll switch
over to YouTube and um maybe we can go
live over there sometime when I have
time. I have time, but I'm kind of lazy
on my dial, so you guys make dua for me,
too.
>> All right. All right. Everything's good
now.
>> You guys stop spamming my chat. Oh,
wait. Wait one second. Avery, stop
spamming my chat. I don't Listen,
listen. You got I'm gonna mute whoever's
doing that. Muslims, stop. Don't Don't
do that. Don't do that. AD, stop. AD,
don't do that. I don't care about that
stuff here. I I don't want to I don't
want to my chat doing that because maybe
somebody has a question for me or maybe
they have a question that needs to be
answered. So, just leave the chat open.
Nobody can come up one. Well, unless
Dahoo wants to drop down um explain. Uh
but I'm only bringing one Muslim up and
one Christian up at a time, guys. So,
Dah, did you want to drop down and make
room for somebody else? A Dood, you
there?
>> Yeah, I'm here. I I got to go cuz I have
to I've got to go into the store.
>> All right, I'm going to bring a Muslim
up here so uh whoever is requesting in
the box first can come up. All right,
let's see who we got in here.
>> I'm I'm ready when when you are
>> ready. I'm bring my brother up. Go
ahead. Go ahead. I'm listening to you.
Go ahead.
>> Okay. Thank you. So um Acts 22 Jesus
being a servant who the father worked
through uh does not negate that Jesus
it's through Jesus that the apostles are
doing miracles by that he's the one
who's giving them miracles which we said
we agreed our common ground was is that
God is the one who gives the miracles
him alone. So, the fact that Jesus is
giving the apostles miracles and they're
doing miracles in Jesus' name and by
faith in Jesus demonstrates that Jesus
is God.
>> And then on top of that with Acts 2,
right before the verse you quoted in
verse 22, it literally talks about how
Jesus is God. Bro, look, if you read
verse 16 to 21,
>> let's read it together. Let's read it
together. Let's read it for everybody.
What's the verse?
>> So, start starting at verse 16 down to
21. Acts 2:16 down to 21. All right,
everybody. If you got your Bibles open,
go ahead and open up Acts 2 16 and we're
going to read all the way down to 21.
All right, here we go. But this is what
was spoken by prophet Joel. And in the
last days it shall be. God declares that
I will pour out my spirit upon all
flesh. And your sons and your daughters
shall prophesy,
and your young men shall see visions,
and your old men shall see dreams. Ye,
and on my men's servants and my maid
servants in those days I will pour out
my spirit and they shall prophecy and I
will show wonders. I will show wonders
>> in the heaven above and signs on the
earth beneath blood and fire and vapor
of smoke. The sun shall be turned into
darkness and the moon into blood before
the day of the Lord comes, the great and
manifest day. And it shall be that
whoever calls on the name of the Lord
shall be saved.
>> Is that where you wanted me to start?
>> Yes. And so now notice this. Who is the
one who's going to pour out the spirit
um upon these people? The spirit of God.
Who's going to pour the spirit
>> upon mankind? Right.
>> Yes.
>> God.
>> God. Exactly.
>> And and by this by the spirit that he
pours out, they're going to be doing
miracles, prophesying, you know, getting
revelation, all kinds of stuff. And he's
going to do many wonders, right? Um and
then it and then he says in verse 21,
this is also important that whoever
calls upon the name of the Lord shall be
saved. Right? So, we got
>> the pouring out of the spirit.
>> This Lord is Jesus Christ, right?
>> Oh, absolutely. 100%. Because watch
this. And it's We don't got to guess
about going to say that. I knew you were
going to say it. We don't got to guess.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. We don't we don't got to guess it
because look when we go down go down to
verse uh go down to verse uh 38. Go down
to verse 38. Well, actually well
actually before that read read 37.
Sorry. Sorry. Read read verse 37 and
then 38. Now, when they heard this, they
were cut to the heart. I'm not sure what
the context of that
>> all of that everything.
>> Okay. And said to Peter and the rest of
the apostles, "Brethren, what shall we
do?" And Peter said to them, "Repent and
be baptized, every one of you, in the
name of Jesus Christ, for the
forgiveness of your sins, and you shall
receive the gift of the Holy Spirit." So
in whose name are they to call on and be
baptized in order to receive
forgiveness?
>> Absolutely. It should be Jesus Christ.
>> So therefore the Lord, everyone who
calls on the name of the Lord will be
saved. Who is that Lord? According to
the context according to Peter, who is
that Lord by which?
>> Jesus. We don't have to guess. This is
Jesus.
>> Okay. So notice
>> Jesus Christ. Beautiful. You have to
call upon Jesus Christ in order for you
to be saved according to this text. Not
>> awesome. Now, according to the according
to the prophecy, the Lord there is God
himself who pours out the spirit.
>> That's not what it says exactly.
>> Yes, it is. What?
>> Let's Let's Can I just That's not what
it says.
>> Come on, Chris. Let's back up. Let's
back up.
>> All right.
>> Calm down, man. Let's back up a little
bit.
>> Can I just
>> One one second. One second. Explain. One
second. I'm going to let you go as soon
as I read this first verse over again to
the audience, right? Because God and the
Lord is not the same here. in these
verses.
>> Oh man.
>> And we can clearly see the distinguish
the distinguishing factors here, right?
So we say uh you you told me to start at
uh 24, right? No, 216, right?
>> 216. Yes. Joel Joel's prophecy,
>> right?
>> I think you should go there,
>> right? So it says, "But this is what was
spoken by the prophet Joel." Right.
>> Yes.
>> And in the last days it shall be God
declares. Who's declaring?
>> God.
>> Good. And what is he declaring? that
he's going to pour out whose spirit.
>> His spirit. Uh-huh.
>> His spirit.
>> Yeah.
>> And who is he going to pour it out upon?
>> On all flesh. The believers.
>> Jesus is flesh, isn't he?
>> No. No. No. This isn't talking about
Jesus. This is talking about those the
followers. Look, this is why.
>> What does all flesh mean?
>> Listen, I need you to understand.
>> I'm asking a question. What does all
mean?
>> I know. I know. I'm answering you. It
means all flesh. I got you. Here's the
point. You're trying to include Jesus in
this. This Jesus is the one who's
pouring out the spirit. He's the one
pouring it out. Which is why in the
context, notice the spirit. If you go up
to Acts two in the beginning, the
disciples are in the upper room and all
the believers in Jesus are in the upper
room and then suddenly the spirit
>> Yeah.
>> You want me to go to
>> Well, no, not necessar not. I'm just I'm
just I'm just I'm just talking about it.
If you want to see if we can
>> Okay. Okay. Go ahead. I'm sorry to cut
you. Sorry to cut the wisdom. Go ahead,
man.
>> It's all right. Yeah. So, if we read
Acts 2 1:4, just breaking that down. The
disciples are in the upper room waiting
and praying, worshiping along with
others believers of Jesus, those who
follow them. And then the Holy Spirit
comes and descends on them, right? And
like tongues of fire is resting on them,
right? Gives them this ability to now
speak in many different languages,
right? Now, so this is what we see. The
Holy Spirit, the spirit of God is poured
on the believers, on the apostles and
those who follow Jesus. This is what is
happening here. And so Peter is saying,
"Hey guys, we're not drunk." As you are
guys are saying, because they were
saying, "Oh, these men are drunk. They
got to be drunk. How do they know our
language?" yada yada yada. He's saying,
"We're not drunk, but this is the work
of Jesus Christ. This is the work of
Jesus Christ who the prophet spoke of,
Joel spoke of said this would happen."
He spoke of this very thing that God
said he will pour out his spirit upon
all flesh and they will prophesy and
yada yada yada. Right? So Jesus is the
one. He's the God. He's the Lord who
poured out his spirit upon the flesh
causing the disciples to have miraculous
power and abilities and it's at it's on
his name that all are to be called are
to be saved and get forgiveness of their
sins. And just to be clear for you too,
Joe, um I almost called you Joel. Joe,
when you go to the prophecy, when you go
to the prophecy and I think this is good
for us to go to the original prophecy
because here we see it says Lord here,
right? cuz it's the Greek, you know,
Hebrew and Greek. Lord, here it's Lord.
It's Kios. In the Hebrew, in Joel's
prophecy,
>> it's Yahweh. It says, "All who call on
the name of Yahweh shall be saved."
>> Yeah.
>> Showing that Jesus is that Yahweh that
that you have to call upon. Jesus is
Yahweh according to Peter. You see, so
this all of this demonstrates that Jesus
without a shadow of a doubt is God. He's
Yahweh. He's the God who pours out the
spirit. He's the Lord on who all we're
supposed to call on for the forgiveness
of our sins and be saved. Him alone. If
we go to Joel 2.
>> Before we before we move on, move
forward. Okay.
>> I wanted my brother explain because he
wanted to add something to our
conversation if you would allow him to.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh explain. Just don't take us somewhere
else. We are on a point right now.
>> No, I just I'm reading too as well.
Who's being addressed here? Is it just
the Jewish people or the Gentiles also?
Raise your mic just a little bit. A
raise your mic just a little bit.
>> Yeah. Sorry. Um, so in this conversation
in Acts two, who's being spoken to, is
it the Jewish people that have come from
all the other places or is it the
Gentiles too?
>> In this particular context, it's the
Jews.
>> Okay. Right. So the Jews are being
addressed here. So let's look at it
carefully.
>> Okay.
>> Now they were staying in Jerusalem,
God-fearing Jews from every nation under
heaven. When they heard this sound, a
crowd came together in bewilderment
because each one heard their own
language being spoken. Utterly amazed
and they asked, "Aren't these all
speaking Galileans?" Then how is it that
each of us hears them in our native
language right now? What's this message
that's being delivered? Sorry, just let
me get back to my garden office. It'll
take a second. Uh you guys do that. I'm
>> We're losing you, man.
>> Please put the charger on. uh having
some technical issues there to explain.
All right. So, while we're waiting on
the brother to get his mic and
everything situated, I'll bring him back
and he can reiterate his point.
>> But I want to go back to um Acts um
21:17, right?
>> Okay.
>> You said remember what you were telling
me in the beginning. Just saying no, no,
no, that's just not enough. And I
listened to you carefully, your
rebuttal. I listened to your rebuttal,
>> but basically you repeated yourself. In
other words, you added more things, but
it's basically the same repetitive type
of thing that you were saying that okay,
the the the spirit that's being poured
out is uh being done by the Lord, right?
But in 217, it doesn't it doesn't say
that the Lord is going to do that. It
says that God is going to do that. Now,
I have an answer for you when you when
you talk about uh moving from Kios to
Yahweh. Those are two different things.
But I'm going to I'm going to save that
point for another point, right? I'm
going to save that for somewhere else.
Right now, we're dealing with the New
Testament and and the verse that you
took us to. Okay? You took us to this
Acts 21:17 and initially what it's
saying is that God is going to be
pouring out the spirit, but you say you
say it's the Lord pouring out the
spirit. The Lord and God is two
different things. How do we know?
because it says clearly in the text, I
will pour out my spirit upon all flesh.
And when I asked you, is Jesus flesh?
You said yes. It's just that simple.
It's not a hard argument. It's a very
easy argument for anybody in the chat to
understand that God is pouring out the
spirit upon all flesh, which includes
Jesus Christ. So if Jesus Christ then
falls under the category of the men's
servants and made servants who are going
to prophesy and who are going to have
visions, ultimately miracles. You see
how that works? Just like going back to
Acts 2:22, God is the one giving the
miracles and signs to Jesus. Just like
in John 5:26 and 27, God is the one who
or 27, God is the one giving authority
to Jesus. You see, so ultimately it all
go it all goes back to the same
argument, Avery, is that a man doesn't
have any way to prove his divinity. He
doesn't have a way to do it because he's
a man.
>> Okay. I don't know. I I was disappointed
in that. I'm not going to lie to you.
And here's why. Let's use
>> the argument is clear.
>> Okay. Let's let's use this reasoning.
You're saying that Jesus is included
when it comes to all flesh and this
prophecy, right? So, let's do this. So,
is Jesus included when it says everyone
who calls on the name of the Lord shall
be saved? Is Jesus included in everyone?
>> Yes. Yes. Why do I say that? Ask me why
I say that.
>> Why do I say that? Ask me why. I I'm
afraid to cuz Creed you you just you
you've been holding on to the point you
>> don't ask me why then don't ask me why I
won't get I
>> I won't Creed you literally agreed you
literally agreed that um that Jesus is
the Lord that everyone has to call upon
to be saved. So that would mean that
he's excluded from everyone the everyone
who's calling upon him upon him. Right?
He's not calling upon himself to be
saved. Right?
>> According to you, he is right. Am I
wrong? Am I [laughter] wrong? If
according to you, he is in the triune.
He's triune. Right? So he's calling upon
himself according to you. But if you
take my point of view, then no, he's not
calling upon himself because he's not
God.
>> So you can't have it both ways.
>> Okay. So I'll ask again, Creed. Who is
the Lord that everyone has to call on to
be saved according to the prophecy here?
>> Jesus Christ. He's the one that God
says.
>> All right. Okay. So, does Jesus Christ
have to call on himself to be saved?
>> No, he doesn't.
>> So, then he's not
>> he's already saved initially because
he's the one he's he's the catalyst of
the saving. So, for instance,
>> wait. He's not going to call upon
himself. Wait, wait one second. One
second.
>> All right. If I if I if I dub you as my
scribe, for instance, now we can talk
logically, right? If I say to you,
Avery, I'm going to make you my scribe
and I give you a pen. And I say to you,
everyone, everyone that comes in and
wants to be a part of our program, I'm
going to need you to write their name
down. Now, by default, you're already a
part of the program because you're my
spy. You understand? So everybody coming
in doesn't include you because you're
already there. God chose Jesus first.
Everybody else follows. So the every
here is not like the every in the other
verse that says all flesh. You can't
conflate the two issues. One, by
default, Jesus is set up meaning that
every that follows him wouldn't be him
because he's already been set up by God.
But when God said that he poured out his
spirit on ALL FLESH, THIS WOULD include
Jesus because he hadn't set up anything
previously uh for flesh. He said he's
going to pour out all flesh.
>> Okay. All right.
>> That includes Jesus Christ. Do you
understand my argument?
>> I I understand your argument. I don't
think it's a good one, but I understand
your argument. So, I want I want
>> it. I don't care.
>> I got you. I don't want I don't want to
I won't take too much of your time. I
want your thoughts on this last point.
Okay. Um, so Acts 2 is quoting a
prophecy from Joel. This is Joel chapter
2, he's quoting verses 27-32.
Okay. In in the prophecy where it says
where we're seeing in Acts 2 where it
says, "Everyone who calls on the name of
the Lord shall be saved." In uh in Joel
2, who is that Lord that they have to
call on to be saved? If we go to Joel 2,
according to the original prophecy,
>> let's go to Joel 2. Joel 2. All right.
Hold on a second. Okay, let me just pull
it up. Joel 2 and what was the verse
again?
>> It's 27-32.
>> 27-32. All right. So, I'm already
guessing that it's going to be Jesus.
It's always Jesus.
>> That's right. It always Jesus. You You
admit he's God, man.
>> It's It's always Jesus, baby.
>> Always Jesus.
>> Praise God.
>> All right. Joel Joel uh 22 27. Maybe I'm
in the wrong room. It says, "You shall
Is that how it starts? You shall know
that I am."
>> Yep. Yep.
>> All right. You shall know that I am in
the midst of Israel and that I the Lord
am your God and there is none else and
my people shall never again be put to
shame.
>> So who's the Lord? So who's the Lord
according to the prophets?
>> Explain explain explain this explain
this verse to us.
>> Explain these verses to us
>> that we're we're identifying who it is.
So
>> because I don't I don't really know what
it's saying. I don't know what it's
saying. I don't understand.
>> But God God is talking about his
redemption, how he's going to redeem and
save and save people, not just Israel,
but all people as you're going to see.
>> Um, okay.
>> Who is who is the Lord here according to
who's speaking?
>> Could be.
>> Okay. Here, um, I would say that the
creator of the heavens and the earth is
calling himself lord. There's no problem
with that.
>> Awesome. Okay. So, he continues, keep
going. So, the creator of the heavens
and the earth, God refers to himself.
This also is this also um let's see
[clears throat] the Greek on this one
too. I want to just check it real quick.
>> Okay.
>> The Lord this is Yhovah here. So not
kios
>> that's that's actually that's the
Hebrew. That's the Hebrew. If you if you
open it in the in the Greek it does say
kios. Yeah. In the Greek in the Greek it
says kios.
>> What do you mean
>> in the in the septuagent?
>> No words. We can check it. We can check
it. We can check it.
>> Okay.
>> But in any particular case what's your
point here? So the Lord according to
Joel 2 is God himself, right? Okay. So
he says yes. All right.
>> God himself. Yes. It doesn't mean that
because it's mentioning Lord that all of
a sudden that anybody who's called the
Lord is God.
>> I agree with you. Not everybody who's
called Lord is God. But in the context
here, the Lord here is God. Can we
agree? Okay, cool.
>> Yeah, I I think so. I mean, like I said,
I don't I don't know the context. You
probably know better than me, right? You
read the Bible a lot. I don't read the
Bible as much as you, but I I'll take
your word for it. You know, maybe I
shouldn't, but I will. And we're going
to say here that yes, it's talking about
God is that's what it appears to be.
>> Awesome. Okay, so now we're going to
keep reading and see what God the Lord
says all the way down to 32. Okay,
>> let's take a look.
>> Remember, this is what Acts
>> This is what Acts 2 is quoting verbatim.
So, it's all right. Go ahead.
>> Okay, let's see. And it shall come to
pass afterward that I will pour out my
spirit on all flesh. Your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy. Your old men
shall dream dreams. And your young men
shall see visions. Yes, it's a direct
quote.
>> Very good. You know your Bible, young
man.
>> Thank you.
>> Good, man. Your Bible.
>> Even upon the men's servants and maid
servants in those days, I will pour out
my spirit.
>> Let's see what it says. Now, this is
interesting. The day of the Lord. And I
will give port tents in the heavens and
on earth,
>> blood and fire and columns of smoke. The
sun shall be turned into darkness and
the moon to blood before the great and
terrible day of the Lord comes. And it
shall come to pass that all who call
upon the name of the Lord shall be
delivered. For in Mount Zion in
Jerusalem, there shall be those who
escape as the Lord has said, and among
the survivors shall be those whom the
Lord calls.
>> Awesome. So now in Acts two,
>> I like that verse. This is a good this
is a great this is a good argument. Let
me say this is a good argument, but it
it doesn't it doesn't necessitate that
Jesus somehow becomes God. And I'll tell
you why if you let me go ahead.
>> Okay. So according to the verse, the
passage, the Lord who's doing all these
things, pouring out the spirit, being
called upon, right? It's it's God
himself. Can we agree? And so, and so
Peter quotes this in Acts 2 and applies
this to Jesus. So, Peter is saying that
Jesus is the Lord God of the Old
Testament who was speaking, telling us
in the future what he's going to do.
He's the Lord. He's the God.
>> Peter is saying what?
>> Yeah. Peter Peter is saying that Jesus
is God. the Lord God who spoke back in
Joel 2 who foretold what he's going to
do that at the name of the Lord every
whoever calls on the name of the Lord
shall be saved and that Lord there in
that context of Joel 2 is God himself
it's not just any Lord it's God so Peter
is is saying that
>> why you say that why do you why do you
believe that Peter is saying that though
what makes you believe that Peter thinks
that
>> because Peter literally said that uh
that Job that Job prophesied this about
Jesus. These days he prophesied these
days about Jesus. He remember we read
Acts 2 16 to 21. He apply he quotes the
prophecy of Joel 2 and applies it to
Jesus. So he's saying Jesus is the Lord
God of Joel too.
>> Got it. I understand you. So there's two
ways to look at this and then I want to
respond to you too. There's two points.
Did you want to say something before we
get uh ahead of ourselves? Uh uh brother
explain.
>> Yeah. Just hold I'm going to hold my
thought. I know you got to go. I know
you got to go. But just let my brother
just chime in because he's been waiting
and I want to respect him and let him
>> the point, but I got two quick things
that I want to just add to the
conversation. So, don't run off on me. I
know you probably got to start your own
live or something. So,
>> no. Yeah. I I'll hear you I'll hear you
out. I'll hear you out last and then
I'll and then I'll bounce. I'll hear
your point. All right. Go ahead.
Explain.
>> All right.
>> Yeah. I just wanted to ask. So, how did
you come to the conclusion that Peter is
referring to [snorts]
Jesus as God? So, Joel's come along,
he's given you a description of these
final days when everything's going to be
in turmoil and um you know, he's
promising the Israelites, you know, that
they're going to be punished and so
forth. And then essentially here um
Peter is referring to Jesus. So we're
talking about Acts two, right?
>> Yes.
>> Right. So in Acts two for example here
um Peter addresses the crowds and Peter
stood with the 11 raids with his voice
and address the crowd fellow fellow
Jews. So he's talking to the Jewish
people here. These people are not drunk
da da da in the day in the last days God
God says so he's he's quoting Joel here
in the last days God says I will pour my
spirit on all people right so all the
people he's going to sp pour his spirit
on. Your sons and daughters will
prophecy.
So everyone will be prophesizing, right?
Your sons and daughters. So basically
the Jewish people's children because
he's talking just to the Jewish people.
So your sons and daughters will
prophecy. Your young men will see
visions and your old men will see
dreams. Again, he's referring to the
Jewish people. Even on my servants, both
men and women, I will pour out my spirit
in those days, and they will prophecy. I
will show wonders in the heavens above
and signs on the earth below, blood and
fire, and billows of smoke. the sun will
be turned to darkness and the moon to
blood before the coming of the great and
glorious day of the Lord and everyone
who calls on the name of the Lord will
be saved. [clears throat]
Now, did Job ever mention that the
Messiah would be God?
>> He doesn't have to.
>> And why?
>> Because he's just talking about what God
himself is going to do. And then when we
get the further revelation, we already
got the other prophets who say that the
Messiah is God. And then we got Jesus
revealing that he is God here,
>> right?
Come. Sorry. Uh, how I'm not
registering. Maybe I'm a bit slow here.
How is Jesus saying that he's God here?
>> Okay. So, well, it's Peter. It's Peter.
So, so look at this. We agree that Joel
is referring is that God is speaking in
Joel too about what he's going to do,
right? Pouring out the spirit.
>> Uh, pouring uh pouring out the spirit
and making them prophesy, all this kind
of stuff, right? Do wonders and all this
kind of stuff, right?
>> Yeah. Peter says, "Jesus is the one who
poured out."
>> You guys hit the logic a lot. You can
support the live, too. I'm here, too.
>> Yeah. Y'all make sure y'all tap the
screen, man.
>> Hit that heart.
>> Yeah. Show some love.
>> Talk right there. Support the support
the live, guys. We have conversations.
>> All right. So, so explain. So,
>> God says, "I'm going to be the one
pouring out my spirit upon the flesh.
>> They're going to prophesy and do wonders
as a result of this. And all who call on
the name of the Lord God me will be
saved. Right? Peter says this is Jesus
that whoever calls on the name of Jesus
shall be saved. He imply he quotes Joel
2 of this passage and says this is about
Jesus and he literally says Jesus is the
one who poured out the Holy Spirit upon
the flesh. So Peter is saying this is
about Jesus that Jesus is the God who is
speaking in Joel 2. Which verses does
Peter say that this is referring to
Jesus and he's the one who's going to
pour out the Holy Spirit?
>> Verse 33. Verse 33.
>> We got We got quite a few verses. Got
verse 33 is where
>> Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. Right. Just bear
with me. Right. Okay. So 22 23 24. But
God raised him from the dead d and I saw
the Lord before me because he is and
therefore my heart was glad my body was
in rest and hope you made known to me
the parts of life. You filled me with
joy in your presence fellow Israelites I
can tell you 32 did you say confidently.
>> Yeah. Right. Okay. So but he was a
prophet and you go and promised him the
good place and seeing what has to come.
He was the Messiah. Right. seeing what
was to come. He spoke of the
resurrection of the Messiah that he was
not abandoned to the realm of the dead
nor his body is decayed. God has raised
Jesus to life. And so God has raised
this Jesus to life. Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. There's a distinction between the
father, the God, the father and Jesus.
No, there's no problem with that.
There's a trinity. So talking about
Jesus here, watch this.
>> Yeah. So God has raised this Jesus to
life, right?
>> What verse what verse is that? Sorry.
>> 32. Okay.
>> Right. So, God has raised this Jesus to
life and we are all witnesses of it,
exalted to the right hand of God. He has
received from the father the promised
Holy Spirit. So, he's receiving this
from the father. Correct.
>> Mhm. He received the Holy Spirit from
the father and watch what he does with
it.
>> And has poured out what you now see and
hear.
>> So, you see how So, pause there. So you
see how Peter says that it's Jesus who
poured out the spirit,
>> right?
>> God has raised Jesus exalted to the
right hand of God. He has received from
the father the promised Holy Spirit.
Right.
>> And then Yes. So he's been given it to
pass on. Correct.
>> Yep. So the father says here, here's the
promised Holy Spirit. Jesus takes the
Holy Spirit and pours him over the
flesh. Exactly what the prophecy says
God is going to do. says, "God is the
one who
>> I know you guys are listening in the
chat. I know you guys are Stop spamming
the chat. I know you guys are listening
in the chat. If you understand the
question that the brother explained is
uh kind of asking uh Avery and if you
understand Avery's response, give me a
one because I don't want you guys just
sitting not learning, not understanding
what's being said, right? Listen
carefully about what's being said
because ultimately your faith hinges
upon what you believe. If you believe
what Avery is saying is true, you must
understand what he's saying, not just
listen to whatever he's saying just
because he's Avery. Okay? Listen to
what's being said. If you believe that
what the brother explain is saying, not
just because he's making an argument,
but because you actually understand. So,
try to pay attention everybody. Uh,
appreciate you guys uh uh uh in the
chat, you know, kind of hanging out with
us. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So it says here, sorry, April,
exalted to the right hand of God. He has
received from the father the promised
Holy Spirit and has poured out what you
now see and hear.
>> Very good.
>> So David did not send uh to heaven and
yet he said the Lord
>> Wait, wait, wait. Don't don't don't skip
forward. So right right here
>> we see that Jesus is the one who pours
out the spirit. Correct.
>> Yeah. Only because the God's given him
it.
>> No worries. They don't do it. They don't
do anything apart from each other. So,
the father giving him the promised Holy
Spirit and Jesus being the one who pours
it out is no problem. Here's the here's
the kicker. Okay.
>> According to the prophecy, who is the
one who pours out the spirit?
>> God.
>> Exactly. According to Peter, wait, wait.
According to Peter, who is the one who
pours out the spirit?
>> God through Jesus.
>> No, he doesn't say God through Jesus.
Again, it does.
>> Who Who is the one according to Peter
pours out the spirit? I'll read it to
you verbatim. God exalted to the right
hand of God. He has received from the
father the promised holy spirit and has
poured out what you now see and hear.
>> Who? All right. Who poured him out? Who
poured out the spirit?
>> Yeah. So Jesus has poured it after he
received it from God.
>> No worries. So Jesus is the one who
poured out the spirit. So Peter says
Jesus is the one who poured out the
spirit. Joel says God is the one who
pours out the spirit. You put two and
two together. Who is Peter saying Jesus
is?
>> Somebody that God does miracles through.
>> Okay.
>> It does. It literally said that in 22.
>> Hey, with with that I you know I want to
hear you I want to hear you create and
then
>> let me just bring it back. I mean you
guys that's a good argument. Uh
>> no but
>> he says it there. I'm quoting from the
same chapter, right? A couple of verses
before, right? People of Nazareth,
right, fellow Israelites, right? Okay.
Um, okay.
>> It's okay, bro. I gota I gotta hear
Creed out so I can so I can go
somewhere, man.
>> Sorry. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I know he has to go. Let me let me
just make my last point and then Avery
can make his last point and we'll go
ahead and end it, guys, because it's
getting late anyways. I'm going to
probably only be on live another 10, 15
minutes. I'm going to bed. It's late
where I am. So, any particular place,
let me just say that. Let's bring it
back to the point because a lot of
people weren't here. Welcome to CCCTV.
I'm your host, General Creed. Uh today's
topic, if you haven't been following
along, this is what we're talking about.
Christians, how did Jesus demonstrate
his divinity? Okay. Uh a person can make
claims. Anybody can claim anything. And
God himself is the one that gives
miracles. So, a person that does
miracles, it doesn't make them God. So,
this is what we're trying to prove or
show. How did Jesus demonstrate his
divinity? I have my guest here, Avery,
and my guest uh uh uh explain my
response to all of what has been said so
far because all I've heard are claims
that have been put forth. One claim by
Peter, that's my first point that the
claim that Jesus is God, which my
brother explained, rebutted, so I'm not
going to go back into that again. He
rebuted that. Peter is not actually
saying that Jesus is God. He's actually
saying that he's the one sent by God.
But any particular case, I'll let them
hash that out another time. What I want
to say is that in Deuteronomy, because
the the the point that Avery is making
is that because the people are calling
upon Jesus Jesus as Lord that this makes
him God. This doesn't track. Why?
Because if you look at Deuteronomy
chapter 18 verse verses 18-19
many people believe that this is
speaking about Jesus Christ. Jesus is
being sent as a prophet and I'll read
I'll read here exactly what it says. It
says I will raise up them a prophet from
among their brother like unto thee and I
will put my words in his mouth and he
shall speak unto them all that I shall
command. And it shall come to pass that
whosoever will not hearken unto my
words, which he shall speak in my name.
So this prophet is going to come in
whose name? God's name. And so
therefore, everybody who calls that man
Lord, everybody who calls that man Lord,
they're actually not calling him Lord.
They're calling the creator Lord. That
man is coming in the name of God. And
the people that call upon that man, then
they will get blessed. they will get
saved. So it's an indirect type of thing
according to the Bible. In addition to
that, let me just say it's similar to
what took place in Exodus.
Exodus 7 19-20 where it reads, "And the
Lord spake unto Moses, say, Aaron, say
unto Aaron, take thy rod, and stretch
out thy hand upon the waters of Egypt,
upon the streams, upon the rivers, and
upon the ponds, and upon all their pools
of water, that they may become blood,
and that they may be blood through all
the land of Egypt, both in vessels of
wood and in vessels of stone." And Moses
and Aaron did so, as the Lord commanded.
And he lifted up the rod. Who lifted up
the rod? Aaron physically took this rod
in his hand and he lifted up the rod and
smoked the waters that were in the river
in the sight of Pharaoh and in the sight
of his servants. And all of the waters
that were in the river were turned to
blood. But according to verse 19, it's
the Lord who's doing it, but Aaron
actually did it, but the Lord is saying
he did it. This only goes to prove that
miracles are done or sent by God. And
the person doing the miracle is not God.
Even though if you read those verses
carefully, it appears that God is doing
the miracle. He is, but we know that
Aaron is the one who physically is doing
that thing. Just like Jesus, when he
does something, he's doing it because
he's been ordained to do it. And I don't
know, we can go in a circle with this,
but I'm I'm going to always refer you
back to Acts 2:22.
>> Okay,
>> go ahead. You can make your last
statement. I know you got to go.
>> Appreciate it. All right. So, because
you you kind of made a new argument,
man. I thought you gonna address what I
was saying.
>> I did. [laughter] I did. I knew I was
gonna That's why You see, I WAS HOLDING
BACK THAT VERSE. YOU SEE THAT VERSE? I
was holding back on you. See, now you
want to stay. Don't you want to stay?
But I got to go. You got to
>> All right. So, I I think uh correct me
if I'm wrong cuz I don't want to build a
rebuttal off if if I misheard you. Did
you say that Aaron said that he's the
one who did it?
>> No, no, no. I'm saying the verse uh is
perceiving that Aaron is the one who
>> got you
>> put the staff into the water but
ultimately it's God Almighty.
>> Okay.
>> But when you read the text, you can see
clearly that this is divine agency.
>> I got you. All right. So, um I'll say a
few things.
>> I'll say a few things. Number one, I
agree with you that there is such thing
as divine agency in the scriptures that
God does works through people and the
credit is attributed to God. Here's the
difference. The difference is that
you'll never see the agent claiming to
be God or claiming to be the one who is
doing the work, right? But you when it
comes to Jesus, he says that he's the
one doing it. Not just him, but he also
says the father does it as well. He
makes it clear that he and the father
work in perfect unison. He doesn't work
apart from the father. He doesn't he's
not a rogue ninja where he goes out of
on his own. He's doing his own things
separate from the father. But he does
things in unison in tandem with the
father and the spirit. This is why he
says in John 5, the son can do nothing
of himself, but only what he sees the
father doing. For whatever the father
does, that the son does in like manner.
The same way Jesus just told us that
whatever the father does, he does it the
same way. So with this being said, we
got Peter here. Now remember you said
that Peter's making a claim. The only
reason why we're here quoting Peter is
because you brought this up. You brought
you came here, right? So we you came to
Peter. You used Peter. Just using Peter.
I'm trying to show you what he says in
context. All right. And so what and what
he says is amazing. What we learn is our
common ground that we have. Our common
ground was is that the person doing the
miracle doing miracles doesn't
necessarily make you God. But the one
who gives the miracle, that's who God
is. God is the one who gives the
miracle. No one else. What we
demonstrated in Acts is that Jesus was
the one giving the miracles to the
apostles to perform. And they said it.
They said that we're doing this work not
of our own self. I don't got no money to
give you. I don't got nothing to give
you. The only thing I can give you is
this. Get up and walk in the name of
Jesus. And then he goes out into the
marketplace. How are you doing this?
It's not us. It's by the name of Jesus
and faith in Jesus that this man walks
before you today. So it's the power of
Jesus that the apostles are able to do
miracles which by your standard mean
Jesus meets the criteria of being God.
It's not just a claim. The proof is
being shown. And then to top it off,
Peter says, "Hey guys, you remember
Joel's prophecy that God himself, the
Lord God, said he's going to pour out
his spirit and that he's going to pour
it out on all flesh and that all who
call on the name of the Lord will be
saved." In Hebrew, it's Yahweh. Peter
says that's Jesus. This Jesus is the one
who received the promise of the father,
the Holy Spirit, and poured it out on
all of us. It was Jesus. So throughout
these these passages we see very clear
that we met your standard creed and I'm
happy we was able to do it today that g
through the scriptures we see not just
the claim not just doing miracles but
creed your standard the one who gives
the miracle is God himself and we saw
that Jesus is the one who gives the
miracle alhamdulillah Yeshua. All right,
fantastic. I I appreciate your response,
man. You know, ultimately, I'm not here
to debate with you or be right. That's
not because guidance is not in my hands.
>> It's in the creator of the heavens and
the earth's hands. And my argument, it
stands for whoever understands it. And
your argument is that Jesus is doing
miracles and giving people the ability
to do miracles. So therefore, he must be
the one who
>> he must be God. the origin of the
miracles, but that
>> good night
>> that doesn't that doesn't track and
people and people can read this read
this Bible for themselves and they can
see that it's God who gives the miracles
and you we can disagree all night,
ladies and gentlemen. But I want to
thank you for coming here, Avery.
>> Thank you. Thank you for having me, man.
>> You you keep keep doing Don't change,
please. Cuz the DA team is going to
probably come after you and they're
going to hate you for this. Please don't
change. Keep doing your platform like
this. Um because I'm pretty sure it'll
grow with with how you're conducting
this. All right, take care guys. Thanks,
>> Creed.
>> Bro, can I just say
>> All right, ladies and gents.
>> Okay, man. That was a good one. That was
fun. That was fun.